ok
sotto
dei
ragazzi sto gioco è partito così io non
ho fatto niente bene tutti i ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo nuovissimo gioco
incredibile che non sapremo mai come si
chiama visto che è partito che sto già
camminando cioè praticamente io ho
acceso il computer stavo camminando va
bene non ne so nulla però visto un paio
di scrivere incredibile sembrava
incredibile però sappiamo comunque che
gli per certo il protagonista non sa
guidare questo è sicuro al cento per
cento non sappiamo il titolo ma questo
su questo non ci piove
ma è stato bellissimo perché non mi sono
mosso la retro va bene succederà
qualcosa lei ha fatto è poi morto va
bene dove fratello tony burke deve
cercare il fratello tony chiesta
fratello tony mio zio scar io corro
perché non sono insomma c'è una suora un
po incazzata credo che non debba averci
a che fare almeno non lo so
molti che ha trattato questo correre
all'indietro questa cosa è spettacolare
schiva anche gli alberi che fa al
fratello sony
fratello tony
madonna
che la madonna di dio
nel nome di gesù cristo ti chiedono di
farti cazzi tuoi
si vabbè in terribile è pazzesca questa
qua il ragazzo deve andarci una ragione
a scala fratello tony
fratello dopo che la porta si è chiusa
madonna alla porta è fatta veramente da
cani però reso il gioco sembra una bomba
va bene beh per ora allegro allegro per
essere partito bene sotto intento
sento un cuore che batte non solo
e sai pure lì vado agli orrori del resto
della casa tra cui
e allora io io non vorrei non vorrei
essere indiscreto
mi dispiace disturbare cosa però ci sta
un altra sorella che mi stava trattando
in un poco gas e
su tutte che tutte quante sotto accordo
del tempo si conoscono e dicono a
cacchiamo gli le palle tutti quanti però
questa non mi sa che questa scappa meno
male
paghiamo le bollette innanzitutto prima
e seconda roba ma era una casa di che
tipo questa idolo cercare padre tony
comunque
porca [ __ ] si mangerà prima dove aver
seguito prima perché mi dessi seguirà
destro la cappella equa
padre tony aiuto
se non passa la vita di merda sorella
dovevano far questo cos'è era un
appoggio nelle fogne
tutto questo per raggiungere la chiesa
perché può andare a padre tony ore il
signor padre tony
che gli servirà i puffi sanno che è un
tesoro cioè ma dove cazzo
radio a parte dove che devo andare cos'è
sta roba ma chi è che vive nelle fogne
cos'è c'è una saponetta
mela fanti usarlo ho bisogno di trovare
qualcosa per aprirla sì ma non ci sei
neanche arrivato su travi a due metri
ancora gemmato di salire comunque
accettate la cosa più allegra che ho
visto fino a tesi
no no non è vero non è vero com'è vero
aiuto sono otto
devo fare sua moto
[Musica]
giorno
ti prego fatti i cazzi tuoi io dovrei
andare via
come faccio da me vengo io
vedo che la mia volte fa memoria
attenzione
una chiave eccola qua chi ha detto di
peggio io l'ho trovata ragazzi ci sta la
chiave e adesso può uscire teoricamente
era la chiave nel cassetto da trovare e
che non era presente semplice adesso ci
pesa siamo alla cappella non possono che
ci sia una delle robe al neon e nella
tabella salvezza ei sono 6 segna mi ha
detto io
cos'ha fatto ma non ho fatto niente
va bene
padre tony fratello tony chiunque tu sia
sarà questa la ricetta la chiesa non
sono fatto
niente un libro dei trasporti questo
schifo
non ho capito niente
[Musica]
hai bisogno di andare a bari a ed il
grossista di galano
padre che vuole andare a bari col padre
siamo in chiesa hostess con molto poco
tv di gesù cristo questa chiesa ma siamo
in piccolo qua la croce ce l'abbiamo
signori recitiamo è il default prima
pagina notte successo
perché continua teletrasportare un
macbook air adobe e ti teletrasporti di
4 secondi che devo fare io io ci provate
uscire qua però di fare qualcosa che è
oggi sono svenuto da dove ero va bene
stavo che schifo
stavo svenendo tutto a posto comunque
ragazzi è
bellissimo suono non mi far seguire da
satana per favore stavolta grazie
giovanni
gianni
l'ottimismo
è il profumo di non ricevere jumps che
durante un horror di parigi per quello
lei ma io non ne voglio sapere la prima
volta
a capraia velocissima adesso è
veramente veloce e questo è il momento
più ragazzo però dove entrava dentro
padre tony
perché bevo
adesso mangio di gattesco sulle next
matto perché dove sto andando ragazze
un'ora che vado avanti dove sta padre
jeffrey fratello jeffrey che minchia di
vita sto facendo qua
lo chiedo per corte di re te lo chiedo
perché basta basta essere inseguiti in
coca zio non basta infatti una vita aria
dal prefetto
è un versetto della bibbia 20 29 king
james version ma che cazzo me ne frega a
me è finito
io io io veramente io
perché ha officiato la scrivania da è
partita questa cosa da nulla tra l'altro
al desktop spero che vi sia piaciuto
scritte dal canale al 100 per commento e
non ci vediamo l'anno prossimo video
della ragazza
[Musica]